Speaker 1: Is Disney trying to make children
gay?
You might say, David, that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard.
Even the concept, aside from Disney, how do
you make someone gay?
And I would say to you, Yeah, I know it doesn't
make any sense.
This is the new cultural flashpoint of the
week on right wing media.
Fox Business and others are, I guess, trying
to start moral panic by arguing that a recent
leaked video from an internal Disney conference
call of sorts meeting of sorts is evidence
that Disney is actively trying to make kids
gay or LGBTQ.
FOX Business With the report, Disney exposed
leaked videos, show officials you have to
do the Alex Jones voice when you read something
like those leaked videos show officials pushing
LGBT agenda, saying DeSantis wants to erase
gay kids.
Charlie Kirk right wing.
Individual Charlie Kirk claims Disney is trying
to make your children gay.
Why else would you want to have two dudes
or two women kissing in a Disney film?
OK, what is this all related to?
This all relates to a video from a Disney
All Hands meeting about the Florida don't
say gay bill.
And in this meeting, executive producer Latoya
Gravano says that her team has implemented
a not all seek not at all secret gay agenda.
Now you've got to listen to the video to actually
understand what she's talking about, so let's
do that.
This is the source of the moral panic about
Disney is trying to make your kids gay.
Speaker 2: It's like, I love Disney's content
I grew up watching, you know, all of the classics.
They have been a huge, like, an formative
part of my life.
But at the same time, like I work at small
studios most of my career, and I'd heard hear
whispers like I'd heard things like, Oh, you
know, they won't let you show this at a Disney
show, and I'm like, OK.
So I was a little excess when I started.
But then my experience was that wholly the
opposite of what I had heard on my little
pocket of, like, you know, proud family Disney
TBA.
The showrunners were super welcoming Meredith
Robertson, like our leadership over there
has been so welcoming to like my like, not
at all secret gay agenda.
And so like, Oh,
Speaker 1: how dare she?
But what does she actually mean?
Speaker 2: I feel like I felt like it was.
I mean, like, maybe it was that way in the
past, but I guess like something must have
happened in the last like, like they are turning
it around, they're going hard and then all
that like momentum.
But I felt like that sense of, I don't have
to be afraid to like, let's have these two
characters kiss in the background.
It's like I was just wherever I could, just
basically adding queerness to like, if you
see anything queer, the show was like, OK,
Speaker 1: so you could be like, Whoa, that's
a really weird way of explaining what you're
doing that that's very strange.
But it's abundantly clear that she's not talking
about making people gay what she's talking
about as she has an agenda to show LGBTQ characters
represented in Disney stuff.
It's not like that big of a deal.
Even many, sort of like centrist companies,
recognize that, hey, you know, in like commercials,
maybe or wherever.
In the same way that at one point it became
very and vogue to show, like interracial couples
or just nonwhite parents in commercials, we,
you know, 10, 12 years ago, that was a big
thing.
The same thing is now being done to be more
representative when it comes to content like
on Disney.
And the idea that this is them trying to make
kids gay is just the latest version of moral
panic.
Here's the Charlie Kirk clip.
Listen to how he interprets this.
Speaker 3: It's I know I keep resorting back
to it, but Christopher Caldwell really depicted
the danger of having out of control liberation
movements that are not anchored in legitimate
grievance.
Christopher Caldwell in the book Age of Entitlement,
warned us that the trajectory that we are
on is the very groups that allegedly want
liberation will soon become the tyrants themselves.
In fact, will happen almost immediately, almost
overnight.
That once the groups are formed, it's not
like all of a sudden the ACLU and the LGBT
groups like disassemble like, Oh, we got gay
marriage done now we can just put our paperwork
away.
No, it's an entire cottage industry of outrage
and hysteria gave them meaning and purpose.
And so now it's just nuts not about making
gay marriage legal.
It's legal in every single state.
That was always their big fight.
Now it's about making your kids gay.
Why not?
Why else would you want to have two dudes
or two women kissing in a Disney film?
What it
Speaker 1: maybe because that exists in the
real world, then you want to be representative
of the real world, Charlie,
Speaker 3: the agenda to expose them to it
or to increase the ranks of the LGBTQ community.
What is the process?
People were gay before this sort of nonsense
was happening.
So why exactly are you doing this?
Speaker 1: And of course, the answer is so
simple that that it's just to represent the
way the real world is.
Don't they get the idea is we're just going
to represent that in the world, there's different
types of people.
It's sort of like, I mean, apply it.
We were doing fine when every actor was white,
and in order to have a black character, a
white actor would use blackface, that was
fine.
Why did we need to bring in black actors?
Well, because there's black people in the
real world, right?
I mean, that's isn't it sort of obvious.
And the idea of making people gay is, of course,
absurd, and you all will understand that there
is nothing I could say to my gay friends to
make them no longer gay.
And in fact, when gay people see movies in
which heterosexual couples kiss, it doesn't
make them heterosexual.
OK?
And similarly, there's nothing anyone could
say to me or show me a video of that would
then make me gay.
I mean, it's just it's a ridiculous commentary.
It's an absurd commentary.
The funniest clip I saw on this was from Newsmax
were a Newsmax host said, You know, movies
are just about people.
Why do they have to be about LGBT people?
Well, that's exactly why, because LGBT people
exist in the world and they're people too.
It's very, very strange the level of reflexive
homophobia that comes out.
I don't get this
Speaker 3: be your whole self routine at work
or even in art, even in products that you
are creating for other people to consume.
For instance, take me, I love model trains.
Did you know that I actually do these guys?
They've got a great train set.
I've admired it.
I've helped.
I love trains.
I love them.
I don't talk about it on TV because it's a
pretty niche hobby and not a lot of people
are into it.
All right, especially at my age.
Speaker 1: Being gay isn't a hobby, by the
way.
I don't know.
I mean, this is really crazy.
Speaker 3: That's my thing.
I'll do it on my time, and I'm not going to
bother you about it.
Fare.
You get it.
I think that's a pretty good analogy.
Speaker 1: This is sick.
It's not a good analogy.
Speaker 2: Then there's this.
The show were super welcoming Meredith Roberts,
and our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all secret
gay agenda, I don't have to be afraid to like,
let's have these two characters kiss in the
background.
It's like I was just wherever I could, just
basically adding queerness to like if you
see anything queer the show.
But like, I just was like, no one would stop
me and no one was trying to stop me.
Speaker 3: Just have fun with your not so
secret gay agenda and queerness and putting
it in movies and cartoons and where has it
been so far?
I watch this stuff from time to time.
I guess over the years, these are movies you've
heard of, I've heard of.
Is this what they've been up to all along?
Is this what they will be up to from now on?
I don't think it's going to help the plot
line.
You know, movies are about people.
Why do they have to be about LGBTQ people
or anything like, is the orientation really
all that?
Speaker 1: Well, LGBTQ people exist in the
world, so you would expect to see them in
the movie is a very difficult concept, and
this is the latest moral panic.
It's B.S..
Be aware of it.
It's not going to stop anytime soon.